bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre ce matin sur
notre antenne d audition conjointe de la
commission des affaires économiques de
la commission du développement durable
du sénat sur la transition énergétique
parmi les personnalités auditionnées ce
matin par les sénateurs le climatologue
jean jouzel prix nobel de la paix en
2007 il fait par ailleurs partie du
groupe intergouvernemental d'experts sur
l'évolution du climat
ce groupe vient de rendre son cinquième
rapport dans lequel le climatologue
explique que pour limiter à la hausse du
réchauffement climatique à 2 degrés
seuil au delà duquel est bien le système
risquerait de s'emballer il faut
absolument que les émissions de co2
commence à décroître d'ici à 2020
objectif difficilement atteignable selon
le climatologue alors tout de suite
direction la salle médicis poursuivre
ses auditions bonne matinée à tous mes
chers collègues nous sommes heureux
d'accueillir ce matin cinq membres du
conseil économique social et
environnemental qui viennent de
présenter deux rapports là sur
l'efficacité énergétique des notes sur
la transition énergétique
je salue en particulier madame anne
marie ducroux présidente de la section
de l'environnement du cee se sait la
section qui apportait le rapport sur la
transition énergétique
il me paraît très important mes chers
collègues que les rapports du cse nous
soit présenté
c'est une discussion que j'ai eue avec
jean paul delevoye
plusieurs fois déjà nous avons eu déjà
l'occasion d'avoir la présentation de
certains des rapports je crois que les
relations entre nos deux institutions
mériterait d'être intensifiée en tous
les cas par rapport à la qualité des
rapports que vous produisez
je lui ai dit à jean paul donc je le
redis ici devant vous je crois qu on est
sur un certain nombre de thèmes en tous
les cas totalement en phase en plus vous
avez l'avantagé d'avoir une
représentation de je dirais de la
société civile bien plus large que le
collège évidemment électorale des
sénateurs ce qui vous donne une autre
légitimité j'allais dire et donc je
souhaiterais que ceux-ci s'intensifie
mais je sais que personnellement j'ai un
horaire contraint à 11 heures mais
vraiment vale président de la commission
développement durable et de la mer
edit l'égalité des territoires
ménagement du territoire j'en passe et
des meilleurs sera en mesure de
poursuivre la discussion
l échange qui s'était pas terminé et on
vous propose de commencer tout de suite
par la présentation du rapport
transition énergétique par ces deux
auteurs madame catherine tissot cole et
monsieur jean jouzel
permettez moi mes chers collègues de
faire une petite apparition de présenter
mes félicitations à jean jouzel pour la
distinction qu'il vient d'avoir après
qui est l'équivalent du de la médaille
fields ceci je peux dire dans votre
discipline
oui c'est l'équivalent à peu près après
d'ailleurs un prix nobel collectif
auquel vous participiez est donc bien
sûr on vous propose d'intervenir sur
quinze minutes et pas chacun
non là bien là on a bien compris mais je
précise les chaussées scientifique donc
je préfère le dire ben très pressé
d'aller assez vite et vraiment justes
mots pour également m'associer à tout ce
que vient de dire daniel raoul
et puis
aussi pour vous dire que jean jouzel
malgré tous ces titres et pour lequel je
tiens moi aussi à lui rendre hommage
trouve le temps au mois d'août devenir
un petit village qui s'appelle fleurance
dans le gers pour y animer un festival
je vous le recommande première semaine
d'août
voici le prix nobel viennent parler du
climat c'est que vraiment et c'est que
c'est pour vous donner un petit peu la
dimension de cet homme que je salue bien
sûr je salue aussi catherine sissoko et
je te salue mille autres scientifiques
qui vont nous présenter ce rapport est
bien sûr nous aussi nous souhaitons
intensifier ses relations le cse puisque
dans il ya le mois environnement qui
viennent nous donner sa légitimité en ce
qui concerne autres jeunes commission en
tout cas nous sommes tous ici impatients
de vous écouter
et comme le temps nous est compté je
crois que monsieur jean jouzel vous avez
la parole
bien merci merci à tous les deux de cet
accueil merci de démo sympa vous aider
pour moi alors moi je vous dis
simplement que c'est un plaisir et je
crois un plaisir partagé par part nous
quatre aussi par anne-marie de vous
d'être d'avoir êtes invités à vous
présenter donc ces deux avis là la
transition énergétique et celui sur
l'efficacité énergétique je sais pas
marie tu veut peut-être dire quelques
mots
non merci alors dont je continue donc
nous allons présenter ça à quatre mains
le je pense que je une présentation
générale d'abord c'est vrai que ce
disons le discours sur la transition du
fleuve les journées du 2 septembre ont
été ils ont une présentation très forte
par le président hollande de ces aspects
transition écologique dans lequel dans
laquelle en fait la transition
énergétique qui a une grande place mais
en fait notre réflexion et ces deux avis
avait été disons initiés bien avant un
six mois avant dix ans au tout début
d'année 2012 ou même un peu avant et
donc ça c'est évidemment placé ensuite à
la fois dans ce dans ce contexte disons
de la transition écologique et plus
spécifiquement actuellement
je crois aussi que c'est une nature à
nourrir la réflexion sur le débat
national soit ambitions énergétique dans
lequel nous sommes est également
impliquée alors les deux avis donc je
crois important de rappeler simplement
que ce sont des bons on parlerait de
d'énergie de 10 onces en ce sens le
problème climatique qui me tient à coeur
il ya beaucoup d'autres aspects qui sont
qui sont importants économique bien sûr
environnementaux géopolitique sociaux
c'est tout ça qu'il faut avoir un tas de
se dire que c'est vraiment ils ont des
problèmes multi facettes et évidemment
l'idée date de la vie c'est de traiter
ces différents points alors il ya quand
même un contexte qui m'est cher celui du
changement climatique alors il suit drac
réfection des ressources au-delà même si
effectivement les combustibles fossiles
on va plus on parle plus de plateaux
maintenant de pixar est quand même des
ressources finies c'est très clair et
puis d'une évolution de la demande en
énergie le problème de coût et je crois
et c'est un contexte il est donc
prévisible d'augmentation du coût de
l'énergie que nous avons devant nous
merci pour la diapo suivante sais pas
comment ça se passe qui peut avancer
ah oui moi j'ai rien moi vois vas-y
jacky je te fais confiance
alors bon
bon le contexte donc on va aller assez
rapidement bon en réfection des
ressources fossiles exigences de sûreté
nucléaire c'est vrai que fukushima n'est
pas loin derrière nous loin de là
réchauffement climatique je le redis
choisi simplement qu'il ya un rapport
très fort entre entre l'énergie et
climat et trois quarts de l'augmentation
de l'effet de serre sont liées au niveau
mondial à notre consommation de
combustibles fossiles
c'est très clair bien sûr il ya d'autres
composantes mais il faut bien la voir
sans tête l'augmentation de l'effet de
serre c'est en majorité en large
majorité
disons le les combustibles fossiles bon
nous sommes dans un contexte où il ya
des accords internationaux
malheureusement disons les paroles sont
très très en disons très forte d'une
certain sens ton doigt on doit tout
faire pour maintenir le réchauffement
climatique en tout 2 degrés tous les
pays ont adhéré simplement personne ne
prend le chemin
c'est très fier que nous savons d'ores
et déjà que à horizon 2020 nous aurons
pour le mans 10 15% émission en trop
pour rester sur une telle trajectoire là
parce que cette trajectoire elle et elle
est extrait c'est un véritable défi si
on veut c'est en gros commencé à
diminuer nos émissions dès 2020 et les
diminuer les divise ensuite par trois au
niveau mondial par rapport disant et
donc c'est à aller vers une société
sobre en carbone de façon très claire
pour moi et j'ai enfin vu du prévenu
climatologues ce n'est pas un choix
enfin c'est pas un choix possible c'est
vraiment un impératif avec disons ce
défi très fort vas-y chaki oui je sais
pas qui c'est qui commande c'est bon
alors au plan national évidemment il ya
dix ans à se décline il ya une politique
européenne volontariste avec les trois
favorisons 2020 une directive sur
l'efficacité énergétique dans nos
collègues jacquier à nous parlerons plus
la loi sur l'énergie 2004 voté
pratiquement à l'unanimité qui
effectivement en douce l'objectif pour
la france 2 d'une division par 4 voix
par cinq de ses émissions de gaz à effet
de serre ce qui se place évidemment dans
dans un contexte international une
division non par deux par rapport à 90
plus tôt par trois par rapport à 2020
s'impose évidemment les pays développés
de faire plus il ya disons le grenelle
de l'environnement à 10 ont jeté les
bases d'une réflexion collective qui se
poursuit dans ce débat sur la transition
énergétique
disons avec à chaque fois 10 ont une
disons une composante très forte ils ont
un thème très fort énergie climat
c'est vrai dans les deux cas mais il ya
aussi d'autres aspects évidemment dont
catherine o parler tous les aspects
balance commerciale compétitivité sur
les marchés internationaux
d'opportunités en termes de création
d'emplois c'est vrai que je suis de ceux
qui pensent que la transition
énergétique doit sa coque peut
s'accompagner bien sûr qu'elle doit mais
peut surtout s'accompagner de créations
d'emplois et d'un nouveau mode de
développement et d'études faut pas
oublier les aspects précarité
énergétique
je crois que c'est pour le premier toit
catherine alors nous avons nous avons
travaillé sur cet avis dans la
perspective assez rapidement du débat
qui a été prévu par le gouvernement et
donc d'une loi ou deux lois au pluriel
de textes qui le feront ensuite ce que
je veux dire c'est qu'on n'a pas du tout
fait un travail d'expert mais vraiment
un travail de recommandations pour vous
c'est à dire pour le gouvernement pour
le pour les parlementaires
en osant en fait tracer une route andy
en vous exprimant ce que le cee
souhaitent ou ne souhaitent pas dans la
manière d'aborder ce sujet qui est
extrêmement vaste
alors deuxième chose que je voulais vous
dire en préalable
on a on a essayé de phase et les
recommandations c'est à dire que vous
verrez dans le texte qu'il ya des
recommandations qu'on fait pour tout de
suite
le débat et puis on a essayé de phase et
certaines choses
bon dans cette présentation assez courte
on va peut-être se focaliser beaucoup
sur ce qui est
plus court terme mais vous verrez que on
s'est aussi projeté jusqu'en 2050
parfois troisième point donc on a
structuré le rapport en quatre parties
qui sont d'égalé importance à nos yeux
et qui ça commence par l'idée qui a été
partagé par l'ensemble de la section
environnement est donc très largement
voté par le conseil économique et social
que la transition énergétique doit être
au service de la performance économique
et social la transition énergétique
elle est dans la vie économique et
sociale de la france et particulièrement
dans les pertes que nous connaissons et
qui n'est pas la nécessaire de rappeler
donc ce qu'on souhaite c'est une
économie décarbonée mais aussi
compétitive et écologique en prenant
aussi en compte tous les paramètres
environnementaux nécessaires donc dans
le dans le débat dès le débat nous
souhaitons qu'une clarification soit
faite en particulier sur la notion de
sobriété énergétique l'efficacité
énergétique mes collègues vont vous en
parler c'est assez simple la sobriété
énergétique c'est plus un enjeu de fonds
jusqu'où peut-on aller y at il des
niveaux de contraintes quant à quel
moment comment qu'est-ce qu'on veut ça
c'est un vrai sujet de débat politique
au sens noble du terme
deuxième point il faut intégrer
l'ensemble des facteurs le débat sur la
transition énergétique s'est pas
seulement l'électricité et c'est encore
moins seulement le nucléaire ou pas le
nucléaire donc on insiste sur le fait
mais quand on voit comment le débat
s'engage je pense que ces comprimés
c'était essentiel pour nous de
l'exprimer que c'est aussi les problèmes
de chaleur et les problèmes de transport
les problèmes de transport je le dis
tout de suite sont extrêmement
importants tout ce qui est mobilité et
on vous dit humblement que on n'a pas eu
le temps de le traiter complètement
d'ailleurs le cse va sans doute
s'autosaisir on est en train de
réfléchir pour retravailler sur ces
questions de mobilité durable qui
pourraient relever aussi peut-être d'une
autre section de notre de notre
assemblée
et puis dernière recommandation très
importante dès le moment de ce débat ça
concerne les scénarios nous avons eu
l'occasion pendant le travail qu'on a
fait de l'ird étudier des scénarios de
recevoir des tas de d'experts
extrêmement compétents avec des visions
assez radicalement différente parfois
qui privilégie tel ou tel mix
énergétique ou telle ou telle évolution
de la demande ce qu'on a constaté c'est
que ces scénarios qui sont souvent très
intéressant enfin qu'ils sont
très intéressant pêche en général sur un
point ils ne développent pas
suffisamment tout ce qui concerne
l'emploi
c'est à dire qu'il ya des scénarios mais
ils ne vont pas assez loin pour dire de
manière très concrète objective et aussi
peu polémique et partisane que possible
qu'est ce que ça voudrait dire entre
ceux qui seraient partisans dont on
change pas grand chose parce que c'est
déjà assez difficile comme ça
économiquement et ceux qui imaginent des
changements assez radicaux qu'ils ont
parfois tendance à paré de toutes les
vertus
donc nous ce qu'on demande c'est que
entre les deux et on pense que c'est
vraiment le travail du débat et que vous
parlementaire vous devez interpeller
l'exécutif sur ce point vous avez besoin
d'éléments pour décider il faut
travailler sur ces scénarios le suivant
et puis dernier point pardon c'est très
important sur les scénarios faire
réaliser des études d'impact
environnementales et socioéconomiques de
l'ensemble des scénarios avant de
prendre des décisions
le timing est redoutable d'ici 2020 on a
souhaité aussi je vais juste lire très
rapidement et on répondra à des
questions préserver un service de
l'électricité à coûts de production
réduits
il ya bien eu deux aspects qui ont été
débattus c'est l'accès à l'électricité
si les entreprises sont dans des
périodes de compétitivité internet
international si les ménages ont des
difficultés
ça c'est la manière d'aider la
consommation les consommateurs mais
aussi on fait une recommandation sur la
production à accous aussi réduite
possible privilégier les énergies
renouvelables georges et georges jean il
reviendra mais qui ont un vrai potentiel
de développement économique je te laisse
redire ça dans la party mix énergétique
anticiper l'évolution des métiers je les
dis un petit peu rejoint ce que j'ai dit
sur l'emploi et puis structurée au
niveau national et européen les filières
de recyclage puisque très souvent le
recyclage permet de consommer moins
d'énergie voilà merci on va donc
évidemment catherine a parlé de la
demande mais l'offre est aussi bien sûr
fait partie aussi de ce débat alors on
dit bien que l'offre s'est pas
simplement l'électricité c'est
l'ensemble de leur sera dit de ne pas
focaliser sur le nucléaire
donc il faut essayer d'optimiser aussi
les on va pas reparler des problèmes de
pointe là mais on a un manque
d'optimisation en france de l'offre par
rapport à la demande et en prison s'est
un peu mis une balle dans le pied pour
certains aspects concernant en
particulier ses problèmes de pointe
donc on souhaite vraiment un véritable
débat sur le nucléaire qui sont je pense
qu'il faut il faut la voir dans le cadre
de ce débat soit on est submergé tic et
puis de redire que la problématique des
transports est très importante je
continue ou on continue la voie vraiment
on peut employer
ouais donc d'ici 2020 en terme de dix
ans de production de mix énergétique il
faut on l'a dit regarder des scénarios
qui effectivement répondre aux objectifs
et aux engagements français qui sont en
fait ceux des cylons 13 ans disons en
phase avec les objectifs tels qu'ils
sont définis par la communauté
scientifique sur les énergies
renouvelables concentrer les aides sur
vraiment ceux qui sont déjà mature les
énergiques soient matures on peut penser
à léo l'été reste à la biomasse
voilà on a toute une liste les problèmes
de réseau de transport sont évidemment
très importants leur mort de nice me
leur modernisation et en tout état de
cause nécessaire indispensable même
voilà développer le problème des moteurs
électriques moteur hybride
c'est aussi les moyens dans le transport
sont des pistes pour dix ont essayé de
diminuer la pollution des gaz à effet de
serre du transport et puis on manque
d'une véritable vision en termes de
production d'énergie d'une véritable
vision au delà d'un mandat il faudrait
vraiment une vraie vision une véritable
vision disons pluriannuel et puis d'ici
2030 on pense à 7 d'ici 2030 on pense
aussi vraiment cette électrification des
transports individuels collectifs et
poursuivre le soutien à l'émergence de
filières dans dans ces domaines
troisième chapitre de notre travail
c'est la moby
a sion des acteurs et les moyens nous
n'avons fait que aborder les questions
de fiscalité et de moyens mais avec
quelques recommandations fortes à ce
niveau et notre première recommandation
concerne les acteurs nous souhaitons que
dès le débat soit clarifier les rôles
respectifs des acteurs publics
on a eu l'occasion de re et d'ailleurs
ça touche aussi la loi de
décentralisation
on a eu l'occasion de rencontrer des
élus des élus de terrain de territoire
qui avait géré qui gérait des
initiatives tout à fait intéressante
pour autant on pense qu'il ya un
véritable travail à faire entre la
coordination la gestion de ces
initiatives locales aller vers plus de
territoriale territorialisation sans
perdre la vision générale et après de
nombreuses réflexions nous notre
recommandation en tant que c'est eux
c'est de faire en sorte qu'il y ait deux
acteurs principaux dans cette affaire
d'une part l'état qui doit rester le
garant le responsable de la cohérence
générale de tout ce qui touche à la
fiscalité etc
et puis ensuite le niveau régional
auquel nous pensons qu'il appartient de
coordonner et de gérer ce qui se passe
sur le territoire de la région
alors ça veut pas dire bien sûr qu
aucune initiative n'est possible au
niveau des communes ou des communautés
de communes
mais on pense que il faut faire
attention tout le monde connaît la
problématique du mille feuilles
administratif français et il faut faire
extrêmement attention à bien clarifiée
d'autant plus qu'on ira vers plus de
d'initiatives locales et de territoriale
territorialisation ensuite ensuite quand
il y aura eu cette clarification
naturellement il faut renforcer les
programmes opérationnels territoriaux
qui vise les différents aspects énergie
et notamment la maîtrise de la demande
en énergie
donc je crois qu'on peut vous dire
qu'une de nos recommandations fortes
c'est vraiment identifier les acteurs et
faire en sorte de leur donner les moyens
de travailler ensemble de manière aussi
efficace que possible pour l'ensemble
des parties prenantes
on s'est autorisé aussi de
recommandations plus internationale la
première c'est de dire que le seuil de
soutien bien sûr l'engagement de la
france vers un accord international
équitable en matière de climat et
d'énergie c'est fondamental et ensuite
slide suivante on recommande aussi un
développement de la politique énergie
européenne parce que l'europe a
travaillé sur le climat l'europe ne
travaille pas vraiment comme elles
devraient le faire s'agissant d'énergie
on peut aller beaucoup plus loin et
c'est ce qu'on souhaite ensuite pour les
défis du financement deux messages
principaux le premier nous pensons qu'il
faut conserver le marché des quotas mais
que c'est vrai qu'il n'a pas bien
fonctionné et qu'il faut le revoir et
qu'il faut le réguler comme on régule à
marchés boursiers c'est-à-dire avec une
autorité de régulation etc tout en lui
gardant ses caractéristiques de marché
c'est ça la recommandation et
deuxièmement on vous demande à vous élus
de remettre à plat l'ensemble des
mécanismes fiscaux liés à l'énergie
avec trois critères le premier s'est
naturellement l'efficacité du dispositif
fiscal
deuxièmement c'est son efficacité par
rapport aux problèmes énergétiques et
par rapport aux problèmes climatiques et
environnementaux en général page
suivante
alors une fois qu'il aura eu cette
clarification des acteurs et des moyens
associés
étant entendu je le redis comme l'a dit
jean que notre souhait c'est qu'il y ait
le moins possible de financement public
puisque on tente à soutenir des filières
et des orientations qu'ils puissent
devenir autonome économiquement le plus
vite possible
donc ensuite il faut faire partager
cette stratégie est cette politique à
l'ensemble des acteurs on sait tous
qu'en terme de comportement individuel
les citoyens peuvent être ambivalent ou
où il ya des paradoxes
donc il faut expliquer il faut
accompagner on recommande d'associer
l'éducation nationale dans le débat dès
le début et dans les actions on
recommande aussi de s'appuyer sur toutes
les structures de formation et
d'éducation au développement durable qui
existent en france les associations etc
et puis dernier point même si on est
avare de l'âge de l'argent public on
pense que il sera bien employé si vous
faites des campagnes de communication
compte les décisions auront été prises
des campagnes de communication qui
peuvent avoir tout un tas de forme en
associant les acteurs territoriaux pour
bien montrer qu'il y a une volonté
d'évolution qui implique tout le monde
alors à l'horizon pour aller vite parce
qu'on n'a pas beaucoup de temps à
l'horizon 2020 on reparle du marché des
ets vous le verrez dans notre avis il ya
une recommandation importante qui
concerne la bpi et qui concerne le
secteur bancaire en général c'est qu'on
souhaite que le secteur bancaire soit
plus qu'un site est bon d'abord la dp la
bpi mais aussi les autres banques à
aider les acteurs vers cette transition
énergétique et que tout ce qui peut
soutenir tout ce qui peut soutenir leurs
activités dans ce domaine soit fait et
on en parlera aussi aux acteurs privés
pour le pour le leur dire donc oui merci
oui simplement recherche et innovation
ça tombe sous le sens sont vraiment un
des moteurs de la transition énergétique
c'est clair que si on veut à la fois
créer des emplois et disons aussi rendre
cette transition énergétique
véritablement je dirais enthousiasmante
du point de vue économique et du point
de vue écologique il faut aussi ça
s'appuiera sur des innovations et bien
sûr avec cette nécessité d'associer
recherche fondamentale
disons innovation de passer vraiment du
développement de nouvelles filières
ça veut dire qu'enfin on sent que il
n'ya pas une vraie une vraie disons un
véritable audit de de la recherche sur
l'énergie actuellement qui est fait en
france devrait être conduit on attache
aussi beaucoup d'importance aux sciences
sciences humaines et sociales
la transition ne se fera pas c'est pas
simplement de l'innovation technologique
c'est clair que c'est aussi entraîné
tout un tout indices ont tout un
dynamisme dans notre société là je crois
qu'on a vraiment besoin aussi
d'interagir nous-mêmes et effectivement
que les sciences humaines et sociales
s'investissent voilà et puis tous les
problèmes de financement sur lequel je
ne reviendrai pas merci donc
donc voilà donc l'idée c'est vraiment de
regarder ces les financements actuels
2es de continuer à financer mais en
fonction en fonction vraiment de des
projets qui seront mis en place
engager les acteurs français aussi au
niveau européen c'est ce qu'ont redit
aussi pour l'innovation dans la
recherche par exemple aussi on est nous
sommes assez favorable quand même à la
en tout cas à la comptine à continuer à
explorer déployer toutes les pistes de
valorisation de transformation du co2 on
parle de cas disons par exemple captage
stockage
alors là la page suivante peut-être la
dernière en conclusion
merci on est on a été très rapide et on
vous comprenez que nous n'ont pas du
tout fait un travail d'expertisé mais
vraiment un travail pour essayer de
regarder tous les différents aspects de
ce sujet qui est un sujet énorme pour
notre société
donc on pense qu'il faut vraiment
repenser nos fondamentaux pour sortir
d'une crise que nous analysons comme
systémiques
cette transition elle doit être
pertinente elle doit être réfléchie elle
doit être partagée
ça c'est un message important je pense
que le travail qu'on a fait avec tous
les membres du ce et ceux issus de
différents horizons qui ont abouti à ces
recommandations montre que ce travail de
partage sur des grands enjeux est
possible et en résumé nous pensons qu'il
faut associer volontarisme et
progressivité
vous avez compris de tout ce qu'on a dit
avec gens qu'il faut donner un prix au
carbone un prix raisonnable pas un prix
ridicule qu'il faut permettre
l'adaptation de tous les acteurs il faut
être ambitieux mais il faut vraiment
mettre des systèmes de monitoring pour
voir comment ça se passe concrètement il
faut améliorer la gouvernance faire
évoluer en profondeur la fiscalité bâtir
une véritable robe de l'énergie investir
dans la r&d et la transition entre la
r&d et l'industrialisation et développer
des filières économiques pérennes voilà
et nous nous avons confiance dans le
fait que notre pays doit le faire et
peut le faire à son bénéfice
non mes chers collègues la séance de
question est ouverte
je vous demanderais de rester sur le
thème qui est qui vient d'être évoqué
est ce que nous aurons un deuxième
rapport sur la performance énergétique
ce qui t'a notre un autre angle et donc
d'approcher de vous cantonner sur
l'aspect économique emploi tu tel que
l'a souligné jean jouzel et donc j'aurai
une question préalable à vous poser
c'est l'aspect européen comment la
france peut-elle mener une façon
unilatérale d'une telle politique
oui mais dans les préconisations elle
est beaucoup axé sur l'aspect national
quels sont les impulsions là l'ambition
pour moment il ya quand on parle de
politique européenne de l'énergie et
quelque chose nous simplement une disons
plutôt dans la distribution disons
largement de l'électricité il n'y a pas
vraiment de politique européenne sur le
gaz ou sur le fossile disons on peut
dire qu'à une politique européenne en
tout cas au niveau des investissements
une véritable politique européenne doit
se faire déjà au niveau des
investissements et des investissements
futurs c'est vraiment avoir une vision
participer à une vision d'un
développement d'une europe de l'énergie
paru en 2050 qui répondent à ces
objectifs qui sont quand même partagé un
division par quatre qui sont partagées
par l'ensemble de l'europe
donc c'est ça comment on m a passé en
place si chacun fait dix ans on
développe ses systèmes énergétiques dans
son coin c'est c'est vraiment le message
non c'est plus au niveau de la halle de
l'offre alors dans les prises dans les
demandes de parole le monsieur testons
monsieur lenoir courteau didier mirassou
berry de baïdy là donc quand ces chants
qui est un deuxième rapport derrière je
vous demande de très con si mes chers
collègues
monsieur testons merci monsieur le
président madame monsieur vous
préconisez d'accélérer l'électrification
des transports individuels et collectifs
d'ici 2030
alors on ne peut qu'être d'accord avec
cette orientation toutefois avez vous
mesuré l'impact en termes de
consommation électrique de la
généralisation de véhicules électriques
j'ai eu l'occasion de prendre
connaissance de documents établis par
certains économistes
qui a estimé qu'il faudrait accroître
considérablement la production
d'électricité pour un tel cet objet
questions at a fini très bien monsieur
le noir si vous pouvez mais oh la la il
s'est recentré vous me demander d'être
concile ce président vous vous aurez
satisfaction deux points ça commence mal
l'aspect européen est majeur or
constatons le c'est un grave échec
l'europe n'a pas été en mesure de
conduire de définir une politique de
l'énergie
le mot europe apparaît une fois dans le
domaine de l'énergie c'est dans le mot
hope est à présent le sigle le p r le
réacteur ppr veut c'est europe européen
pour le reste on n'a pas de politique
c'est un premier point deuxièmement
concernant le véhicule électrique
l'objection qui est fait peut être
combattue le problème de la france c'est
la pointe
c'est à dire que nous avons une
consommation atypique
or ce qu'il faut faire c'est développer
la recherche dans le domaine de la
conservation du stockage de l'énergie et
le véhicule électrique est un bon moyen
de le faire
troisièmement ce trappe mon dernier
point la question de la formation est
essentielle
je trouve que nous avons à réfléchir
collectivement aux emplois qu'il faut
créer aux formations qu'il faut
développer car dans ce domaine là il ya
beaucoup à faire mais si monsieur
courteau trois questions monsieur le
président
ne pensez vous pas que le secteur des
transports 130 millions de tonnes de co2
contre 87 millions de tonnes de co2 pour
le résidentiel tertiaire a été le grand
oublié du grenelle de l'environnement et
qu'il doit devenir une priorité deuxième
question développement des énergies
renouvelables
doit-il obligatoirement passer par un
tarif de rachat attractifs et que penser
de la cspe actuelle faut-il compte tenu
de l'art d'oise de ces milliards je
crois la réforme et élargir son assiette
envisager des financements
complémentaires pour les énergies
renouvelables
troisième question concernant la
fiscalité française de l'environnement
il semblerait que la france soit très en
retard par rapport à l'ensemble des pays
européens
oui fiscalité pas assez vers liège noté
est trop grand nombre d'exonérations ce
qui m'amène à aborder le problème du
financement de la transition
dans un contexte de crise qui raréfie
l'agent public
faut-il regarder du côté de la bpi bien
vous l'avais dit je crois madame faut-il
donner la priorité aux pme et aux tpe
qui sont dédiés à la transition
énergétique
ou faut-il mise âgé dé participation
citoyenne dans les projets locaux de
transition énergétique et dernière
question monsieur le président dernière
question mais je ne la trouve point je
rejoint pour terminer ce qui a été dit
petit d'avoir une politique européenne
climatique et pas de politique
européenne de l'énergie où chaque état
membre prend les décisions
unilatéralement ses beats part formulé
ma question madame evelyne didier merci
merci monsieur le président première
question
ne pensez-vous pas que nous avons
tendance lorsque nous préconisons des
des politiques de peser d'abord sur le
citoyen en pensant qu'il est en tant que
consommateur celui qui peut réorienter
les choses
est-ce qu'on ne donne pas trop de poids
à cette optique la deuxième chose vous
avez indiqué qu'il fallait réformer le
marché carbone
pensez vous qu'il existe d'autres outils
et lesquelles sachant que jusqu'ici il a
montré assez peu d'efficacité un
troisième chose j'ai noté avec que vous
aviez effectivement parler du temps du
transport individuel à côté du transport
collectif
on a un peu tendance là également à
penser que le transport individuel doit
être réduit drastiquement si c'est
possible dans les agglomérations
ça l'est beaucoup moins dans les zones
rurales et donc voilà importance que
vous y apportez et dernière question
pensez vous que la recherche à tout prix
de nouvelles ressources carbonées n'est
pas contraire au développement de la
transition énergétique bon madame assure
marin et je vais être très brève gérer
simplement revenir sur la dernière
diapositives que vous avez passé vous
avez dit que la transition énergétique
ne sera pas uniquement technologique et
vous avez parlé de préconisation d'un
investissement d vous est préconisé un
investissement des sciences humaines
vous avez parlé de campagne de
communication je peux vous dire que je
suis absolument totalement d'accord avec
vous on néglige trop souvent que aucune
transition ne pourra se faire sans des
changements de comportements et
d'attitudes et donc sans évidemment
campagne de prévention et tout ce qui va
avec je pourrais même parler de
marketing social au niveau de la
transition énergétique
donc si vous avez des éléments à me
communiquer à ce niveau là je suis tout
à fait preneuse
et je veux prenait la parole simplement
pour dire que je vous suis totalement
sur ce point monsieur venir merci
monsieur mirassou
oui pour joindre ce qui a été évoqué à
l'échelle européenne on a compris que la
problématique s'escrimer d'un échelon
planétaire et donc on peut supposer que
ce qui va marcher ici ici tout ce qui a
été évoqué abouti pourra s'intégrer dans
une politique européenne et qui parce
qu'elle aura les potentialités pourra
unir quelque chose en déclic en quelque
sorte à l'échelon à l'échelon mondial
pourtant on a bien compris qu y compris
à l'échelon européen
il y avait des formidables distorsion en
termes d'habitudes de consommation
d'histoire que sais-je
ce qui me laisse à penser que l'on
pourrait là comme ailleurs envisager de
faire un saut qualitatif en ayant sous
la main quelque sorte les états qui
serait le plus avancé dans ce domaine-là
sans pour autant attendre que ceux qui
sont largement de ça se mette à niveau
donc est ce que vous partagez mon
produit par rapport à ça et puis je
rejoins complètement à ce qui a été dit
je n'arrive pas moi ce qui me concerne à
me satisfaire du fait qu'il va y avoir
une consommation en termes d'énergie
exponentielle vitam aeternam voilà ça ça
me taraudait dit monsieur dit l'un je
vais très très con si monsieur le
président parce que je voulais mon tour
évoqué l'europe de l'énergie ou plutôt
l'europe de la transition énergétique
qu'on voit vraiment pas venir et en
particulier dans les discussions
budgétaires actuelles à l'europe
vraiment donc je vais je être très
rapide
peut-on rêver d'une sorte d' eads de la
transition énergétique
ah c'est une belle formule ce ça vient
du corps médical évidemment monsieur
bérit-debat oui ma question touchent
plus particulièrement la problématique
du transport en commun et vous faites
vous faites allusion ou vous préconisez
d'utiliser des énergies renouvelables
telles que les biocarburants de deuxième
et troisième génération alors pour que
pour les la voiture vous êtes plutôt
pour le tout électrique
alors est ce que vous pourriez
développer c'est en sachant que les
transports en commun c'est pas
simplement des problématiques à
l'échelle de grandes villes mais de deux
villes moyennes et qu'on se retrouve là
je dirais contraint à utiliser même avec
des bus à haut niveau de service
essentiellement des réseaux de bus
donc comment entrer dans cette
problématique au niveau des transports
en commun à l'échelle de deux villes
moyennes ou d'agglomération moyenne r si
la parole est aux rapporteurs madame
messieurs mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs d'abord merci de vos questions
je pense que elle nous montre que ce
qu'on vous a exposé ne vous laisse pas
indifférent ce qui nous paraît le le
plus important c'est vous avez nommé
vous rebondissez sur de nombreux aspects
de notre travail donc c'est intéressant
je jouerai je rappelle que nous nous
sommes au cse nous travaillons pas
complètement à plein temps pour le
conseil économique donc nous reflétons
les travaux qu'on a fait on n'a pas
forcément eu le temps d'aller au bout de
toutes les expertises et je pense
vraiment que ce que vous dites montre
qu'il y a des choses à approfondir au
moment du débat et puis ensuite dans les
décisions il et les textes qui seront
faits alors je dis pas tout ça pour
botter en touche mais c'est vraiment
vraiment très important je retiens de ce
que vous nous dites qu'il ya pas mal de
questions sur les transports alors on
vous a dit qu'on reconnaissait ne pas
avoir approfondi le sujet donc on est
conscient que c'est un énorme sujet le
rapport entre transport individuel
transports collectifs les types de
carburants etc
je ne peux que vous renvoyer à notre
notre avis où il ya quelques pages un
peu plus précise que ce qu'on a dit mais
vraiment on n'a pas l'ambition d'avoir
trouver toutes les solutions sur
l'aspect européen
alors vous avez raison moi je pense que
la bonne nouvelle pour vous et lui sait
que nous société civile on vous dit
qu'on croit à l'europe dans une époque
où on parle de scepticisme de citoyens
qui n'y croient pas et c'est quand des
citoyens de bonne volonté comme ceux du
cee travail quelques mois ensemble sur
un sujet comme ça ils arrivent
immédiatement qu'ils soient
syndicalistes écologistes entreprises ou
associations de terrain ils arrivent
immédiatement à la question de l'europe
donc je pense que c'est un soutien pour
vous je ne permettrais de dire
aujourd'hui aussi que le fait que le
ministre des affaires européennes
deviennent ministre du budget bon
peut-être c'est une opportunité aussi
d'avoir un lien particulier avec une
personnalité qui qui qui va connaître
ces deux aspects donc là je vois là
c'est tout ce qu'on peut dire on est
conscient de tous de tous les problèmes
européens
autre point aussi la france tout seul
dans le monde bah oui ça c'est aussi le
risque c'est pour ça je pense qu'on a
autant insister sur le premier volet la
performance économique et social la
compétitivité l'emploi la qualité des
emplois et la nécessité de faire quelque
chose avec des points d'étapes et des
évaluations permanentes ne pas se
précipiter dans des scénarios qui
pourraient être séduisant mais qui
serait mal évalué on croit qu'il faut le
faire mais il faut le faire de manière
graduée quant à la fiscalité ben oui
nous on pense en particulier dans la
section environnement qu'il faut plus de
fiscalité écologique moi en tant que
représentante du monde des entreprises
je dis pas plus de pression fiscale ça
c'est sûr mais on peut la rééquilibrer
on peut la rééquilibrer et mettre plus
en cohérence notre fiscalité et nos
engagements écologiques
voilà l'essentiel de ce que je voulais
vous dire rapidement et le ads de la
transition énergétique monsieur pourquoi
pas vous voyez qu'on appelle à la
création d'entreprise et de business
donc faut-il imaginer quelque chose
pourquoi pas voilà je laisse gens
commenté oui alors j'ai pas j'ai pas
beaucoup de commentaires additionnels or
ce don donc moi moi moi je suis fait
deux ou trois points vous souhaitez
transports je pars bon je pense qu'on a
passé travail et c'est ce qu'on a dit je
pense à bien réfléchir sur l'europe pour
moi je suis aussi de ceux qui pensent
quand même il ya tellement d'initiatives
différentes entre l'allemagne et la
france que se mettre ensemble et ça
serait quand même très porteur donc il
faut pas faut quand même pas je veux
dire il ya vraiment important je ne
pense pas qu'on y arrivera et c'est vrai
sans une politique coordonnée climatique
énergétique au niveau européen c'est
très clair et je pense que s'il n'y a
pas cette si l'europe n'arrive pas à
tenir ses objectifs
elle ne sera pas non plus il ya quand
même une puissance ils ont un certain
pouvoir d'entraînement de l'europe par
rapport au monde
il faut pas rêver et donc c'est au
niveau européen que ça peut se jouer
donc sur sur la fiscalité
c'est clair bon jeu bon je lis beaucoup
je ne suis pas du tout s'éclaire s'en
donne pas un pré significatif au carbone
c'est la seule façon de sortir de faire
la transition énergétique
c'est cesser on est dans un monde où il
ya une économie mais si on donne pas un
prix au carbone
c'est vrai au niveau international on
peut se poser la question au niveau
français au niveau européen mais on doit
donner un prix au carbone si on veut
disons réussir cette transition
énergétique alors sur le gaz de schiste
on a plutôt discuter un peu en creux
mais c'est clair que disons nous sommes
il ya eu beaucoup de discussions vous
connaissez les problèmes des gaz de
schiste je rappelle simplement que c'est
avant tout quand même un gaz à effet de
serre et que ce n'est pas dans ce
domaine du gaz naturel je veux dire que
s'il ya des fuites par exemple c'est
beaucoup de discussion là dessus
disons-le à le
le gain le gain de passer du charbon du
pétrole ou gaz ne vaut pas probablement
pas pour le gaz de schiste ça c'est un
premier point et problèmes
environnementaux ceci étant nous sommes
tout à fait favorables à un débat sur
sur ces problèmes de gaz de schiste et y
compris d'ailleurs dans le débat
national sur la transition énergétique
donc je suis moi-même de membres du
comité de pilotage donc je pense que là
dessus aussi faux pas il faut pas voir
ta bouffe avoir un débat mais avec tous
ces éléments bien en tête
voilà sur nos réponses merci merci
indépendamment des gaz de schiste il pas
le problème de leur technique qui pose
qui est le plus important parce qu'entre
importés et du gaz venant de l'extérieur
et le produire localement
le problème est le même au niveau
carbone bien on passe ce deuxième sujet
mais si j'ai bien compris c'est vous
monsieur qu'il commençait à billets
voilà d'écouté jeu
je vous remercie effectivement qu'on ait
la possibilité nous exprimer je voudrais
d'abord dire en introduction de la
génération double la consommation
d'énergie et donc c'est un élément par
rapport à une question qui a été posée
qui m'apparaît important
alors voilà alors nous nous avons traité
la question de l'efficacité énergétique
et l'efficacité énergétique c'est quoi
c'est consommer moins d'énergie pour le
même service rendu alors le contexte
vous le connaissez le paquet climat
énergie 3 faveur le grenelle alors le
paquet climat énergie 3 x 20 je rappelle
que l'efficacité énergétique c'est le
seul domaine qui n'est pas contraignant
le grenelle de l'environnement la
directive européenne sur l'efficacité
énergétique qu'il faudra transposer dans
un délai rapide a dit le président la
république et le débat sur l'énergie sur
la transition énergétique qui vient d
indiquer à l'instant alors ce qui nous
apparaît important c'est si l'objectif
communautaire de 20% d'économies
d'énergie quels objectifs prévus par les
directives d'efficacité énergétique par
rapport à 1990 et si l'objectif du
grenelle de l'environnement sont
atteints alors l'efficacité énergétique
sera la première source d'énergie
domestique à l'horizon 2020 c'est dire
qu'il ya un enjeu qui est un enjeu tout
à fait considérable et qui est souvent
méconnu donc je dis bien première source
d'énergie domestique
alors ensuite le jour es10 rapidement
que les objectifs sont évidemment très
ambitieux et qu'à l'heure actuelle il
faut être clair ils sont très difficiles
à atteindre
alors on a traité nous la question du
résidentiel et l'industrie nous n'avons
pas traité la question du transport
parce que la question du transport est
une question qui a sa propre logique sa
propre dynamique notre section en plus
ce n'était pas compétente pour les
transports et nous proposons nous avons
proposé en tout cas où ses yeux que le
cee s'empare aussi de la question du
transport parce qu'il ya des questions
tout à fait central des questions
d'urbanisme des questions d'étalement
urbain des questions de substitution ça
a été indiquée de moyens de production a
d'autres qui nous apparaissent devoir
est de traiter
donc nous nous avons traité le bâtiment
résidentiel et tertiaire et l'industrie
aussi l'agriculture un peu le bâtiment
résidentiel et tertiaire ses 44 % la
consommation d'industrie 21 alors donc
j'en arrive effectivement aux bâtiments
résidentiels et tertiaires je donne
quelques chiffres qui nous apparaissent
tout à fait éclairant 44 % la
consommation d'énergie c'est le bâtiment
33 millions de logements dont quatre
très énergivore 55 % du parc construit
avant toute réglementation thermique 55%
avant 1974 en réalité 75 % du parc 2050
déjà construit donc ça montre l'inertie
en réalité de cet aspect 88% l'heure ça
c'est une indication le grenelle de
l'environnement avait fixé un certain
nombre d'objectifs à atteindre 88 % des
objectifs du grenelle porté sur le
bâtiment 12 % porté sur le transport
il y avait aucun objectif qui portait
sur l'industrie on a voulu rappeler cet
élément là ensuite on insiste beaucoup
sur un point c'est le président la
république le premier ministre un
certain nombre de ministres ont annoncé
500 milles rénovation par an à compter
de 2013 c'est à dire à compter de cette
année il y avait 400 milles dans le
grenelle de l'environnement nous avons
cité les chiffres y en a eu deux cent
soixante mille en 2011
voilà et donc
voyons à travers ça qu'il ya un gap
assez considérables qui nous faudra
évidemment comblé si on veut arriver à
ces chiffres qui sont tout à fait
ambitieux en revanche nous mettons à
côté de ça un volume d'emplois qui nous
a été quantifié alors c'est il ya un peu
de difficulté mais entre 100 à 150 mille
emplois qui seraient générées par le
fait d'atteindre 500 milles rénovation
dans le bâtiment
c'est dire qu'il ya un enjeu qui est pas
un an je mens voilà même si
effectivement c'est difficile alors nous
avons pointé un fait un certain nombre
de propositions sachant que notre avis a
été votée à une 90 plus de 90% des voix
donc qui traduit une comment dirais-je
un consensus très large de la société
civile par rapport à ces propositions
la première proposition que nous avons
mis en avant et c'est assez dans le
débat public d'aujourd'hui c'est de
confirmer l'efficacité énergétique comme
une priorité nationale ce que nous avons
dit c'est dès lors que le président de
la république est venu en particulier au
cse nous indiquait que cinq cent mille
logements c'était une ambition que la
politique de rénovation était une
ambition était un des grandes ambitions
de son quinquennat
nous avons considéré que le fait de
passer de 7 5 à 10% après la tva sur la
rénovation après qu'elle ait déjà été
augmentés peu de temps auparavant était
un contre signal et nous avons donc
proposé dans ce contexte là de baisser
la tva à 5% au titre des biens et
services de première nécessité nous
avons considéré que la fiscalité est
bien elle devait se met au diapason de
l'orientation politique sinon les
acteurs on aurait déjà un problème de
crédibilité de la parole publique et de
difficultés pour atteindre des objectifs
dont on vient de montrer déjà qu'ils
étaient extrêmement éloignée de
l'ambition nous avons ensuite pointé un
certain nombre de 2,2 de questions qui
nous apparaissent fondamentale une un
des aspects qui nous apparaît
fondamental c'est la question de la
rénovation du tertiaire
le grenelle de l'environnement a fixé
des objectifs de rénovation du tertiaire
que ce soit public ou privé
il ya des questions de financement à
côté de ça mais surtout le décret qui
doit définir la nature et l'étendue des
obligations de travaux qui permettront
aux acteurs de d'appliquer finalement
cette disposition légale ce décret n'est
toujours pas sorti résultat les acteurs
sont dans l'incertitude
résultat c'est que les acteurs ne
s'engage pas de peur que les travaux qui
vont faire ne soit pas suffisant au
regard du décret à sortir ce décret il
devait sorti depuis 2010 il n'est
toujours pas sorti et nous avons
beaucoup attiré l'attention des
ministres concernés pour dire si vous
voulez que la profession si vous voulez
que le bâtiment s'engage là dedans et
bien il faut aussi que les collectivités
publiques parce qu'il ya du tertiaire
public il ya du tertiaire privé et bien
s'engage et que pour s'engager va
falloir définir exactement ce qu'on veut
y ait un débat sur le degré d'ambition
de ces normes
mais nous nous disons ce qui est est
maintenant important c'est d'arrêter un
débat pour savoir s'il faut faire plus
ou moins c'est de sortir le décret de
telle façon que le mouvement en faveur
de la rénovation se fasse nous avons une
deuxième proposition qui est une
proposition que nous nous avons
découvert au fil d'un travaux c'est
développer l'efficacité active c'est à
dire qu'en fait tous les travaux jusqu'à
présent ce sont faits sur la
réhabilitation des bâtiments
or il y a avec les moyens électroniques
nous avons des leaders mondiaux comme
schneider par exemple qui offre des
possibilités d'avoir des réductions
d'économie d'énergie avec des coûts
moindres
et avec une efficacité extrêmement
sensible les chiffres ont été donnés par
la profession sont des chiffres tout à
fait conséquents de l'ordre de 20%
d'économies d'énergie alors dans notre
esprit soyons clair ça ne se substitue
pas aux travaux sur la rénovation du
bâti c'est du plus mais ça ça n'avait
pas été pris en compte et on s'aperçoit
qu'il ya une amélioration de techniques
en réalité qui est de plus en plus
important et j'ai vu de schneider
faisait tellement dans le cadre de la
transition
un certain nombre de débats sur ce sujet
là et ça c'est quelque chose
que nous avons découvert et qui nous
apparaît important en plus on est leader
mondial donc voilà un élément important
ensuite nous pensons parmi les
propositions que nous avons fait nous
pensons qu'il faudra tendre vers une
garantie de performance de travaux nous
pensons que si on met beaucoup d'argent
dans la rénovation
si les particuliers les collectivités
publiques les tertiaire privé mettre
d'argent
il faudra bien à un moment ou un autre
on est des outils permettant de garantir
que les travaux qui ont été faits eh
bien il ya les bénéfices attendus à côté
alors il ya des débats notamment dans le
cadre du plan bâtiment durable ex plan
bâtiment grenelle sur la nature des
garanties juridiques à apporter ce que
nous disons c'est qu'à un moment il
faudra bien que les gens et les
économies attendues
si on veut que les investissements
soient faits et si on veut en
particulier que les particuliers qui ont
déjà des problèmes de financement qu'on
connaît comme l'état au demeurant mais
que les particuliers s'engagent
voilà et donc ça c'est quelque chose que
nous avons aussi pointé comme étant un
élément une sorte de condition de la
réussite
si on veut que le mouvement se lance
alors ensuite on a un certain d'autres
éléments ce sont les derniers en termes
de propositions nous avons
l'accélération et l'innovation dans la
formation des professionnels
nous avons tous pointé que la question
de la formation des professionnels était
une question centrale
nous avons beaucoup travaillé avec les
artisans notamment de la capeb pour
faire évoluer pour challenge et pour
échanger avec eux sur voila et nous nous
pensons que toute façon rien ne pourra
se faire si c'est pas fait avec les et
les professionnels du secteur
soit dit en passant dans le bâtiment 98
% des entreprises ont moins de 10
salariés
98% donc par conséquent ariane pourra se
faire si on ne travaille pas avec eux
nous avons beaucoup échangé nous avons
fait je crois un peu évoluer leur point
de vue un moment mais nous nous avons
cette conviction nous avons aussi la
conviction qu'il faudra travailler mieux
entre le neuf et l'ancien vous ai
expliqué que c'était l'ancien qui était
le problème
le 9 globalement je veux dire il ya des
réglementations et sont ce qu'elles sont
mais
l'ancien c'est l'appui un certain nombre
de gains il ya sans doute des échanges
plus fort à faire et puis il ya des
formations a conforté par exemple la
formation fée bat formation qui
aujourd'hui est financé par les
certificats d'économie d'énergie en fin
deuxième élément nous souhaitons
réaffirmer l'éco conditionnalité des
aides publiques c'est à dire que en
réalité ce que nous souhaitons c'est que
ça avait été promis par le gouvernement
précédent comme étant une option au 1er
janvier 2014 c'est que l'éco ptz
depuis ce est accordée que par des
travaux pour des travaux par des
entreprises qui seraient labellisés
ce que nous souhaitons c'est que on
pousse vers l'amélioration de la qualité
il ya un certain nombre de deux labels
qui ont été donnés ces labels sont
conditionnés un certain nombre de
formations
nous nous disons si vous voulez que les
artisans se forme est il des incitations
à se former il faut qu'il ya quelque
chose en contrepartie
sinon ils ne le feront pas ils ne seront
pas incité à le faire au demeurant même
surfi bat il y avait cent mille
formation pour un média n'a eu cinquante
mille le fait précisément parce que tout
le monde se regarde les uns les autres
en attendant de savoir qui est ce qui va
commencer et en essayant de voir s'il ya
des avantages ou non à se former ensuite
nous avons la question de l'implication
et de l'information des citoyens
je rebondis sur ce qui a été dit un peu
tout à l'heure d'abord sur le
comportement et ça a été évoqué par
certains d'entre vous dont je n'insiste
pas mais il ya des éléments qui nous
apparaissent importants sur la question
des compteurs communicants
nous avons une proposition sur la table
que le gouvernement précédent avait
décidé la généralisation mais il y avait
une question de financement mais le
gouvernement actuel a aussi décision de
considérer socialisation pardon excusez
moi voilà sur l'hymne ticketpro c'est
une proposition de erdf il y avait une
généralisation décidées par le
gouvernement précédent mais il ya un
pacte de financement il ya encore une
généralisation décidées par le
gouvernement actuel mais n'y a toujours
pas de financement donc la question se
pose sur cet élément là il ya des tests
ont été faits pour savoir dans quelles
conditions les citoyens usagers
consommateurs pourront être mieux
associés je crois que c'est important il
ya aussi des possibilités dans le gard
parce qu'il ya un projet pour les 11
millions de dhs usagers du gars je me
dépêche
ensuite deux éléments suivants il ya la
question de l'individualisation des
charges de chauffage dont les logements
collectifs j'attire votre attention sur
le fait que la directive européenne qui
vient d'être votée par enfin qui vient
de rentrer en vigueur prévoit qu'à
l'horizon 2017 ce loi cela devra être
généralisée sauf contrainte tout à fait
particulière voilà ça date effectivement
depuis quinze ans il ya 10% aujourd'hui
de deux charges de chauffage qui sont
individualisés je crois que parmi ce que
vous devrez avoir en tête sur la
transposition de la directive il ya cet
élément qui nous apparaît tout à fait
important et puis il ya le diagnostic de
performance énergétique vous avez vu
qu'à travers la ppl brottes ya eu
beaucoup de critiques des députés des
sénateurs sur ces diagnostics nous nous
pensons que le diagnostic qu'il est fait
aujourd'hui n'est pas très parlant pour
les gens et nous souhaiterions qu'il y
ait un diagnostic qui soit qui se
traduisent par un coût par mètre carré
et par kilowattheure qui permettrait aux
gens de mesures a effectivement ce que
ça consomme alors qu'aujourd'hui et le
fait d'être exprimée en énergie primaire
n'est pas significatif de ce que ça
consomme donc voilà sur le alors dernier
élément c'est l'actualité c'est la
tarification progressive
alors là je suis sur des pincettes je
dois dire que voilà notre conseil
notre conseil a dit deux choses la
première chose c'est que nous avons des
désaccords entre nous sur le fait de
savoir si la tarification progressive
est quelque chose de positif certains
pensant c'est positif d'autres pensées
négatives y compris d'ailleurs entre co
rapporteurs mais en revanche nous sommes
tous d'accord pour dire que le mécanisme
tel qu'il a été adopté qui soumis au
conseil constitutionnel n'est pas un
instrument de justice sociale voilà nous
avons voilà monsieur le président ce que
nous avons dit
je pense que sur le diagnostic que vous
posez nous étions en phase quelles que
soient les bancs de notre assemblée donc
on continue
alors pour pour continuer sur ce thème
parlons un peu financement quelques
chiffres 6 en a un objectif de 500 mille
logements par an à raison d'en moyenne
20 à 30000 euros par rénovation ça fait
10 à 15 milliards d'euros par an l'état
finance aujourd'hui 2 milliards et le
coût de l'énergie va continuer à
augmenter
je reprends aussi certains éléments le
prix du carbone n'est pas incitatif à
faire le fica sites énergétiques et un
certain nombre de choses qui font qu'il
n'ya pas tellement d'incitation
aujourd'hui à faire de l'efficacité
énergétique
alors quelques propositions tout d'abord
sur la bpi puisque la bpi existe on en
parle beaucoup mais on voudrait
absolument que les entreprises
intervenant dans l'efficacité
énergétique ne soient pas oubliés et
soit vraiment reçoivent une part en tout
cas une part significative des
investissements puissent être fichés là
dessus on l'a vu je vous rappel le
chiffre de dire que si on atteint les
objectifs c'est la première source
d'énergie domestique ça vaut le coup
d'investir pour y arriver
la deuxième chose c'est le tiers
investissement de tiers investissement
s'est pas encore complètement
mis en place en fin très développée il
ya des expérimentations à des niveaux
régionaux et locaux
mais il semble qu'ils aient quand même
un potentiel alors ça réglera pas tout
le tiers investissement mettant dans le
pub dans le privé que dans le public
le tiers investissement si on prend en
compte le djia investissements je
rappelle enfin au cas où mais c'est le
fait que certains investissent pour
voilà on compte de tiers donc si on
intègre la valeur verte des bâtiments
c'est en intègre un certain nombre de
choses il ya des intérêts fort à ce
qu'il puisse y avoir une rentabilité sur
du tiers investissement là dessus il ya
des expérimentations qui ont été faites
et sur lequel on peut je pense que c'est
un des on avait intitulé notre notre
paragraphe innover là dessus je pense
que c'est vraiment le secteur sur lequel
il faut absolument innover sur lesquels
on n'est pas allé du tout au bout des
expérimentations alors les certificats
d'économie d'énergie évidemment c'est un
énorme sujet puisque c'est un gros sujet
sur l'efficacité énergétique
il ya eu beaucoup de beaucoup d'intérêt
sur le certificat d'économie d'énergie
sa part a permis de calculer ce qui
avait comme efficacité énergétique
possible pour certains types de travaux
pour certains certains hommes et
matériaux etc
aujourd'hui force est de reconnaître que
le mécanisme devient compliqué c'est
moins qu'on puisse dire est peu
compréhensible par les acteurs donc nous
il nous apparaît au et au delà de ça un
peu transparent et avec des frais de
gestion absolument énorme on nous a
parlé de 30 à 40 % de frais de gestion
pour les certificats d'économie
d'énergie
notre recommandation était de dire qu'il
ne faut pas supprimer les certificats
d'économie d'énergie mais qui nous
semblait important de palets dit
multiplier et en tout cas de recentrer
les certificats d'énergie c'est un
certain nombre de programmes ou d'action
très spécifique qui permettrait de faire
effet de levier et qui permettait d'être
compréhensible dans le 'b to b' par
exemple dans les des intérêts fort mais
il ya vraiment un besoin important il ya
trop d'opportunités et trop
d'opportunisme
sur ses certificats denner d'économie
d'énergie pour que à terme ce soit
réellement efficace
ensuite on avait proposé une étude sur
deux de lancer une étude sur la caisse
des dépôts sur un programme de soutien
l'efficacité énergétique bon depuis la
lettre de mission a été signé pour la
caisse des dépôts la très récemment donc
en tout cas ça a peut-être contribué en
tout cas ça c'est fait pourquoi on est
l'un des rares enfin en tout cas en
europe
on n'a pas de fond qui nous permet de
financer d'efficacité énergétique et
d'aller chercher des fonds au niveau
européen l'allemagne a depuis longtemps
une banque qui est consacré à
l'efficacité énergétique appelle la kfw
et la grande bretagne a lancé en janvier
le green deal avec aussi une banque
spécifique pour l'efficacité énergétique
donc la proposition qui était sur le
tapis et qui a besoin d'être approfondi
par la caisse la cdc climat en
l'occurrence c'était de créer un fonds
dédié à l'efficacité énergétique qui
permet de faire effet de levier
c'est-à-dire qu'ils soient à la fois
prendre ils prennent par une partie des
fonds de des certificats d'économie
d'énergie pour pouvoir faire levier sur
les marchés et en particulier à l'est au
niveau européen cherchait des fonds
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas capacités en
france allait chercher il ya 60
milliards qui sont prévues au niveau
européen sur l'efficacité énergétique en
a pas la capacité d'aller les chercher
donc c'est quand même important et donc
ça nous paraît être donc bon ça va ça va
il va y avoir quelque chose qui sorte
puisque l'état la caisse des dépôts a
été mandatée quelques mots sur la
précarité énergétique
ça nous paraissait important de vous
rappeler quelques éléments 3,8 millions
de ménages sont concernés par la
précarité énergétique ça veut dire
qu'ils payent ils ont plus de 10% de
leurs de leurs revenus qui dépensent en
dépense énergétique est quelque chose de
très important même si je suis désolé on
prend du temps mais le profil de ces
personnes en a en a et a eu beaucoup
d'idées reçues là-dessus 50% sont des
personnes âgées propriétaires vivent en
maison individuelle dans des zones
rurales ou périurbaines
donc c'est absolument important d'avoir
ça en tête
pour la précarité énergétique est ce
qu'on a proposé tout d'abord lancé une
concertation immédiate pour intégrer la
performance énergétique dans les
critères de décence pour la location des
logements
la france peut-elle continuer à louer
des passoires énergétiques vraiment des
passoires énergétiques à des gens à
terme
alors je sais que ça peut pas être fait
en deux minutes on veut pas retirer des
logements du marché
maintenant il est impossible qu à terme
dans les dix quinze vingt ans je ne sais
pas on puisse continuer à louer des
passoires énergétiques telles qu'on fait
aujourd'hui donc nous il nous semble
absolument primordial que ça rentre dans
les critères de décence généraliser une
aide de chauffage pour toutes les
énergies
aujourd'hui les seuls les les énergies
gaz électricité ont d d d d aide au
chauffage le fuel et toutes les autres
énergies non rien ce qui veut dire que
si je reprends mes 50 % de personnes qui
sont en précarité énergétique et qui
sont donc dans des zones périurbaines et
rurales
ils n'ont pas forcément accès à ces
énergies de vives entre guillemets enfin
entendez moi en tout cas qu'il ya une
réelle inégalité aujourd'hui une réelle
inégalité sur l'aide au chauffage qui
n'est pas du tout voilà il ya pourquoi
il ya des énergies qui ont des aides et
pourtant pourquoi il y en a pas donc ça
on l'a pointé de façon assez forte et de
façon concertée dans notre avis dernier
point ça sera une seule slide sur les
nerfs sur l'industrie les industries
s'est beaucoup de ces beaucoup de face
et 21 % de la consommation d'énergie
il ya déjà beaucoup de choses qui ont
été faites sur l'industrie puisque
évidemment ça rentre dans leur compte
mais ça fait partie aussi des idées
reçues il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont
été faites sur la consommation
d'électricité dans les usines etc
quand on parle de process de
l'industriel là c'est beaucoup moins
c'est beaucoup moins approfondies et il
ya des gisements énormes les yeux la
très récemment
pointé alors juste un point très
important sur l'industrie qui mérite
d'être noté y ait une directive
ecoconception robben qui existe depuis
longtemps et il ya une initiative qui
est suffisamment rare pour pouvoir être
noté il ya eu l'année dernière une une
coalition entre des industriels et des
ong environnementales pour réclamer à
l'europe d'accélérer et de renforcer la
les les cocons enfin le l'énorme d'éco
conception des produits en europe
ça nous paraît important parce que
parfois il ya des 10es des reçus en
disant que les industriels bloquent ne
veulent pas aller à voir d'énormes plus
importante enfin ça peut être entendu
là c'est eux qui le demandent d'aller
plus loin et plus rapidement d'abord
parce qu'évidemment c'est une capacité
d'avoir un intérêt compétitif en tout
cas un intérêt sur le sol européen est
évidemment donc de préserver les
entreprises et les emplois et évidemment
sur un pour les ong environnementales ça
une énorme potentiel énorme potentiel en
termes de consommation d'énergie et de
co2 voilà pour vous donner notre
conclusion désolé on a été long
l'efficacité énergétique c'est un réel
marché du futur en en est persuadé et ça
dépendra de la volonté des acteurs des
pouvoirs publics et de la société toute
entière je remercie merci beaucoup
simplement par rapport à ce qui avait
été évoqué tout à l'heure concernant le
bâtiment des douanes vont auditionner
effectivement la ffb la capeb et avec un
discours un peu musclé d'ailleurs de la
part de la capeb je suis pas sûr qu'ils
aient une relation là aussi une
corrélation tous les cas entre
l'annoncent d'ordonnancé concernant le
logement et le discours un peu dur de la
capable de vendre nos commissions c'est
en tous les cas sur le sur la tva et
c'est une coïncidence de dates qui sont
peut-être fortuite
simplement oui mais concernant le fameux
décret concernant les normes
c'est vrai qu'il ya une urgence et que
c'est un cercle vicieux qui est en train
de se mettre en place c'est que le
bâtiment est là capable et cédera
attendent évidemment pour former leurs
leurs futurs employés il se refuse pour
le moment à les embaucher parce que ne
connaissant pas le profil exact
enfin c'est un alibi aussi enfin ceci
étant dit sur performance énergétique il
ya des choses simples à faire qu'on
pourrait faire sans attendre ce fameux
décret mais bon ainsi sortait ce serait
quand même mieux on est en 2013
un décret qui était prévu en 2010 il ya
un petit des retards à l'allumage
madame nique où vous avez la parole oui
merci président donc ce sera à la fois
une remarque et puis une question alors
vous avez insisté sur la nécessité de la
formation et je partage tout à fait cet
avis je pense que nous sommes un certain
nombre dans cette assemblée à le pas à
la partager
notamment celle des diagnostiqueurs
puisque nous avons assisté ces dernières
ces derniers temps à des choses un peu
aberrante et avec des préconisations qui
n'étaient pas à la hauteur des attentes
et en ce qui concerne la formation des
artisans et des professionnels en
général du bâtiment je crois qu'il ya
une véritable nécessité de reformuler je
vais les reformater mais de revoir la
formation initiale
parce que s'il on pérennise de 7 ce qui
est ce qui est ce qu'ils sont des
pratiques actuellement des artisans au
travers de l'apprentissage et que l'on
n'a pas assez formation initiale de
qualité dans le domaine de la
réhabilitation autant que de l'économie
d'énergie nous nous arriverons pas aux
résultats attendus
donc il y à aussi je pense un lien
essentiel à mettre en place entre la
réalisation des travaux et les z qui
peuvent être accordées parce que s'il
n'y a pas de lien entre la qualité du
travail et la mise en place de ces aides
notamment vous avez cité le ptz qui
pouvait être conditionné
une certaine qualité de travaux est en
revanche j'aurais une question par
rapport à ce que vous avez signaler
concernant les incitations qu'il serait
peut-être nécessaire je termine
nécessaire d'avoir des incitations plus
pour l'efficacité énergétique
n'y at il pas un côté pervers dans la
mise en place de ces incitations
c'est-à-dire qu'elles incitent les
artisans à augmenter leurs tarifs dans
la mesure où il ya une incitation qui
est une subvention qui est donné aux
propriétaires qui fait réaliser ces
travaux
il y a automatiquement une augmentation
du coût des travaux ça sert et ça s'est
concrétisé ça s'est vérifié avec les
incitations concernant les panneaux
solaires concernant les packs c'est à
dire les les pompes à chaleur et il n'y
a t'il pas ce risque là et ne
vaudrait-il pas mieux peut-être avoir
des campagnes de communication
intéressante et qui permettent de
valoriser l'efficacité énergétique
puisque la première subvention ce sera
l'économie d'énergie réalisée suite aux
travaux
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs 3 trois observations et et
peut-être une question de de fond très
rapidement en revenant sur le sujet
précédent c'est que comment parler du
rop énergétique alors que la france
défend son parc nucléaire ou tout du
moins se divise sur la nécessité de
maintenir son parc nucléaire
alors que les allemands à coup de grands
coups médiatiques ont annoncé la fin du
nucléaire chez eux et dont ou personne
ne parle ni vous ni les médias ni
personne des centrales à charbon qui
fonctionne à 120% de leur capacité donc
il ya là un véritable problème qui se
lit d'ailleurs au fait que nous
débattons nous avec deux nouveaux en
nous divisant sur le sujet a du gaz de
schiste alors que les allemands finances
95% de la recherche du gaz de schiste en
pologne
donc il y à l'art une difficulté quand
même à parler de l'europe de l'énergie
entre les deux principaux pays ce
dernier point d'observation sur ce sur
ce cette partie là il faut se me
semble-t-il
arrêtez de faire des comparaisons entre
des expériences énergétique des pays de
10 millions d'habitants
est ce comme les nôtres qui ont plus de
50 millions d'habitants la problématique
et les impacts ne sont pas les mêmes sur
le problème de la capeb
le président vous en avez dit deux mots
je crois qu'il faut relativiser les
statistiques de l'artisanat du bâtiment
par rapport aux grandes entreprises qui
du coup disparaissent complètement des
écrans alors qu'ils représentent plus de
30% des effectifs de salariés dans notre
pays
certes 98 2% mais les 2 % représentent
30% des effectifs et pour 70% des
effectifs de la capeb sont des sous
traitants de ces grands groupes sur
lequel on a une possibilité d'action
beaucoup plus facile que sur les 2
millions de l'artisanat sur le la
problématique de du coût de l'énergie
madame je crois que il y a quelque chose
de fondamental c'est quel coût et quelle
meilleure efficacité sur les coups pour
l'énergie en direction de la production
industrielle et le coût de l'énergie en
direction de domestique est d usage pour
les ménages enfin je doutais un peu
c'est un peu ma question pour dire
pourquoi ne pas parler pourquoi ne pas
parler à un moment donné de la nécessité
et des coûts de faire des scénarios qui
exclut dans la situation économique de
notre pays comme celle d'ailleurs de
l'union européenne aide et de la crise
mondiale
pourquoi ne pas faire des scénarios en
excluant la baisse de la tva parce que
je pense que c'est plus réaliste
aujourd'hui et qu'il faut absolument
arrêter de parler de la baisse de la tva
n'est qu'à voir les statistiques de ce
mois ci où la chute des recettes de tva
et de plus de 3 milliards donc on va pas
encore baissé les taux c'est quelque
chose qui me paraît difficile et puis
avoir un scénario aussi qui pourrait
être peut-être taxer un peu trop
libérale mais qui consiste à stopper les
aides avec de l'argent public sur toute
cette problématique qui doit trouver son
équilibre économique
en dehors de l'utilisation de l'argent
des contribuables pour trouver des
équilibres
merci mes chers et première partie de
vos interventions mon cher collègue
c'est concernés le premier rapport qui
nous a été présenté madame evelyne
didier merci monsieur le président je
voudrais évoquer la question de
l'innovation par rapport à la
complexification où la complexité
je m'explique lorsque vous avez vous
cherché à installer chez vous quelque
chose de moderne qui serait de
l'efficacité énergétique
vous vous trouvez souvent debout devant
des installations qui sont véritable
usine à gaz et qui fait que le simple
particulier à des difficultés à
entretenir et à maîtriser ce genre de
d'équipements c'est vrai aussi pour les
petites collectivités locales je viens
de renoncer à installer la géothermie
profonde dans ma commune
tout simplement parce que c'était une
volonté initiale mais ça je passe d'une
facture avec le gaz à condensation de
80000 à 1 166 mille vu les crédits qu'on
obtient aujourd'hui et le peu de
subventions mais je renonce tout
bêtement par des fauteuils de
financement donc innovation et
complexité en particulier pour les
petites collectivités et les
particuliers
deuxième sujet que je voulais évoquer
ces vous avez évoqué la question des
personnes âgées jeu effectivement ce
n'est pas toujours par manque de
ressources que les personnes âgées ruff
ne font pas ce qu'il faut dans leur
habitation bien que ce soit compliqué
lorsqu'on est veuve avec une pension de
réversion mais il y à aussi la question
de je ne sais pas comment m'y prendre
et j'aurai besoin d'un accompagnement
pour m'aider à choisir l'entreprise à
faire voilà les personnes sont fragiles
à tous points de vue et pas seulement
financièrement et donc c'est une vraie
question
merci monsieur renoir en deuxième
semaine
bien merci monsieur président d'abord je
voudrais féliciter les auteurs du
rapport d'ailleurs comme du rapport
précédent il pas les deux sont tout à
fait remarquables
deux observations sur dix dans la
première on y revient concernant la
formation
il devrait essentiel que les artisans
soient formés ainsi que les
technico-commerciaux car ce sont eux qui
vendent qui explique et qui
éventuellement ne donne pas les bonnes
informations
deuxième point il voudrait elle a
vraiment insisté sur la question du
auteur linky on ne peut pas on ne veut
pas espérer faire des progrès dans le
domaine de l'efficacité énergétique si
les consommateurs n'ont pas une
connaissance précise de leur
consommation premièrement et s'il ne
dispose pas d'un outil qui leur permet
de gérer cette consommation
nous avons produit avec mon collègue et
ami ladislas poniatowski un rapport sur
à la demande du président gouvernement
sur le compteur linky
notre conclusion était très positive a
été posée la question du financement
alors ce qui avait été dit à l'époque je
ne pense pas que ce point est connu une
modification
erdf finances et les économies obtenues
permettent de neutraliser le coût pour
le consommateur puisque évidemment 6e
rdf qui finance cette répercute sur le
turpe mais est donc sur le consommateur
mais on arrive à les grid
ouais je trouve qu'aujourd'hui alors que
le gouvernement précédent c'est vrai
avait hésité dans une période quasiment
électorale a lancé le produit
je trouve qu'aujourd'hui il faut
impérativement que le compteur linky
démarre soit généralisé sans compter son
impact en termes d'emploi pour ce qui
est sa fabrication et sa référence au
plan mondial
en tous les cas par rapport à si on veut
maîtriser les effets de pointe et
caetera et par rapport à ce que vous
avez évoqué madame concernant la
tarification progressive
ceci ne sera acceptée que si les
consommateurs maîtrise réellement leur
consommation
monsieur courteau également récidivistes
oui moi je n'ai pas de question monsieur
le président j'ai juste quelques
remarques
creel crise économique énergie plus
chère plus rares menace de changements
climatiques facture pétrolière 64
milliards soit 90% du difficile du
commerce extérieur m effectivement nous
sommes bien obligés de repenser nos
modèles et nos comportements ça c'est
clair
j'y vois deux autres raisons
supplémentaires c'est que le plus grand
gisement d'énergie en france c'est celui
des économies d'énergie et que l'énergie
la plus propre
ben oui c'est bien celle qu'on ne
consomme pas deuxième réseau nous avons
la deuxième raison nous avons là une
formidable possibilité de créer nombre
d'emplois notamment dans la région dans
la rénovation des bâtiments
et par les temps qui courent je vois que
c'est une priorité compte tenu de
justement la facture pétrolière mais
question des transports question des
transports
oui non mais on parle d'économie
d'énergie les traces forcée au charme
innelec je crois savoir que les ruraux
porteurs qu'il soit à droite ou à gauche
géographiquement parlant nous ont dit
que le transport était pour le moment en
stand by vis-à-vis du conseil économique
social et donc qu'ils y reviendront sans
doute mais sur un rapport spécifique
oui bon dos ça veut dire que je ne peux
pas m'exprimer sur les transports alors
je vais passer à autre chose
je vois que de toute façon en matière
d'économie oui c'est effectivement en
matière d'économie d'énergie et
d'efficacité énergétique joie qu'il
faudra du courage politique
beaucoup de volonté politique mais aussi
beaucoup de pédagogie pour que certains
comportements ou certaines
transformations soit acceptée
socialement je pense qu'il faudra aussi
des politiques énergétiques stable sur
le long terme sur le long terme
contrairement à ce que l'on a connu par
le passé car la visibilité devrait être
totale concernant
les politiques concernant l'efficacité
énergétique ou les économies d'énergie
qui ne doivent pas changer tous les six
mois en fait vous avez parlé de
précarité énergétique
effectivement nous sommes conscients de
ce problème conscient également des
inégalités dans l'accès à l'énergie
je signale tout de même l'extradition
des tarifs sociaux à 8 millions de
personnes
pour les personnes qui consomment de
l'électricité ou du gaz certes et je
reconnais que pour les autres
effectivement il ya un problème mais je
crois me souvenir que la ministre de
l'écologie et de l'énergie avait bien
précisé que cette ce problème là serait
traitée dans le cadre de la grande loi
sur la transition énergétique
merci monsieur mirassou dernière et je
donnerai dans leur apportant dans la
ligne directe ce qui est évoqué pendante
excellentissime collègues porto l'a
évoqué tout à leur problème
comportemental
là je vois efficacité énergétique
tributaire de l'avancement de la société
et moi je me demande comment vous
arrivez à calibrer le volet pédagogique
indispensable pour qu'ils aient pas m'a
donné une rupture entre ce que
j'appellerais l'élite intellectuelle
avancée qui au passage a les moyens de
se prémunir en anticipant peut-être par
rapport aux autres cela plat
l'accessibilité au compteur linky autres
et ceux qui au bout du bout soit parce
qu'ils n'ont pas la possibilité
financière de faire un saut
technologique et un le temps qu'on
enferme souvent un peu dans une forme de
fatalisme
avec aussi au passage à l'antenne une
connotation moraliste parce que celui
qui a la voiture de 15 ans diesel qui
polluent ben ils aimeraient bien avant
la voiture hybride sauf qu'il n'a pas
les moyens ni la seule à chanter résonne
depuis donc pour le pas le pointer du
doigt
donc tu as un peu politique que ce que
je dis mais moi je j'insiste sur le fait
qu' il faut pas qu est une facturation
en société on dise qu à terme y a ceux
qui pourront pour de multiples raisons
et puis ceux qui pourront jamais et moi
je suis là pour défendre ceux qui sont
susceptibles de pouvoir même sur
l'esprit qui pourront pas merci madame
le rapporteur vous avez été interpellé
par monsieur hérisson et donc vous avez
la parole
merci monsieur le président donc pour
monsieur hérisson je voulais simplement
dire que en tant que rapporteur nous
nous félicitons de votre intervention
parce que ce que vous souhaitez on pense
que c'est beaucoup ce qu'on a mis dans
notre dans notre avis à savoir en
particulier qu'il faut être extrêmement
économe des deniers publics dans toute
cette affaire de transition énergétique
et les utiliser à bon escient qu'il faut
effectivement favoriser le plus possible
des filières économiquement viable et
qu'il faut faire avant toute décision
toutes les analyses socio économique et
environnemental nécessaire pour bien
équilibrer les décisions voilà donc je
vous remercie de votre intervention
merci monsieur le président donc avec
canon veux vous remercier aussi beaucoup
de l'intérêt que vous avez porté à 1 aux
travaux on a bien conscience que on a
pointé un certain nombre de questions et
un certain nombre d'entre elles
demeurent pas avec la réponse tout à
fait satisfaisante alors je vais essayer
de répondre avec anne sur un certain
nombre de points
bon il ya des questions sur la formation
dont on a dit qu'elle était central qui
sont posées avec deux de sous-ensembles
la question des diagnostiqueurs est une
question tout à fait à part ne croit que
le gouvernement a publié un texte qui
rentrent en application au 1er janvier
2013 qui renforce y avait des choses
tout à fait étonnante on pouvait faire
un diagnostic à distance sans s'être
déplacés bon ben ça c'est des choses
plutôt de bon sens qui ont été corrigés
donc je pense qu'il faudra parce que là
il y avait quand même un certain nombre
de mesures réglementaires qui existaient
qui était tout de même pour le moins
très très très peu exigeante bon le
décret un arrêté plus tôt a été pris qui
rentrent en application au 1er janvier
2013 je pense que la logique
consisterait faire un bilan mettant la
fin de l'année pour voir si on se
retrouve avec des écarts qui ont été
pointés par un certain nombre
d'associations de consommateurs
sans compter les préconisations vous
avez évoqué qui vont du simple au double
voilà donc là je pense que mes gars 5
mai diagnostiqueurs aujourd'hui et donc
je pense que c'est un vrai sujet on
pense que non il est nécessaire en moins
d'attendre ce que les pouvoirs publics
ont décidé de voir si quel est l'effet
que ça produit alors sur les artisans
évidemment c'est tout à fait central
alors la fois j'ai bien compris ce qui a
été dit c'est vrai que c'était hier les
grandes entreprises existent aussi on
les a d'ailleurs auditionné on a aussi
auditionné la fédération française du
bâtiment qui nous avait bien fait
remarquer qu'ils avaient aussi pas mal
d'artisans dans leurs seins donc voilà
donc on a auditionné effectivement les
uns les autres
je pense que une des questions qui est
tout à fait central en fait vous avez
évoqué la formation initiale ça c'est
vrai la vraie question c'est le
travailler ensemble parce qu'en
définitive en touchant à certains
morceaux du bâti vous pouvez mettre en
cause le reste est donc on a je fais
référence modestement à ce qu'on a écrit
page 25 ont fait référence à des travaux
de l'ademe
on a fait référence au plan bâtiment
durable sur lequel il ya eu beaucoup de
réflexion là dessus mais ça c'est une
des clés le travailler ensemble ça c'est
une des clés est une des difficultés
pour les artisans c'est de trouver les
moyens juridiques aussi travailler
ensemble sans devenir nécessairement que
des sous traitants voilà et donc c'est
une difficulté qui mesure mais sur
lequel on a pointé que tel ou tel aspect
bon la question du contrôle aussi tout à
fait évidente c'est à dire mais le
problème c'est qu'il fait le contrôle
est ce que c'est l'état est ce que ces
deux éléments
mais il est clair qu'à un moment donné
plus on demandera des exigences de
qualité puis il faudra bien qui est
quelqu'un qui a un moment apprécié le
caisson de qualité bon voilà on a par
exemple sur l'éco ptz un blocage tout
bête qui fait qu'on demande aux banques
d'être finalement garonne ce qui est
stupide
bon nous on a proposé que ce soit des
artisans qualifiés qu'ils le fassent
sinon ça sert à rien sinon résultat
c'est qu'à presque pas d'écho ptz qui
ont été délivrés donc il ya des
questions qui sont posées là dessus
alors ensuite sur les incitations les
côtés pervers c'est vrai nous avons
d'ailleurs pointé qu'il ya une question
de maîtrise des coûts on a auditionné
lui et feu qui nous a pointé sur les
panneaux solaires sur un certain nombre
de choses des questions comme ça dans un
premier temps on avait envisagé une
sorte de pacte avec la profession et
puis cette idée on l'a pas fait
prospérer parce que c'était assez
difficile
je pense que parmi les idées qu'il
faudra c'est que c'est clair que si on
met beaucoup d'argent y compris de
l'argent public et l'argent privé
il faudra bien que l'ensemble de la
chaîne 1 et qui sait pas forcément celui
qui est en bout de chaîne d'ailleurs qui
est responsable mais que l'ensemble de
la chaîne fasse des efforts en ce
domaine parce que sinon effectivement
c'est pas normal que certains éléments
soit trois fois plus cher que dans les
pays d'à côté bon donc c'est une
question qu'on a pointé aussi cette
question de maîtrise des coûts alors
ensuite sur la tva parce que c était dit
tout à l'heure
moi je fais remarquer juste une chose
c'est que ce que nous préconisons c'est
le retour à ce qu'il y avait il ya deux
ans 1 parce qu'en deux coups on est
passé de 5,5 à 7 5 7 5 à 10 pour 1er
janvier 2014 et là c'est le retour à ça
que nous préconisons donc en réalité
c'est le pardon oui alors j'ajoute qu'il
ya d'autres aspects qui concernent le
bâtiment qui concerne le travail au noir
qui ont été pointés par la capeb et puis
par la ssb y compris un donc la question
elle et elle et elle est tout à fait
elle est tout à fait celle là donc
j'ajoute aussi que chiffres de la
profession
l'augmentation de tva actuel ces dix
sept mille emplois en moins le seul
parti du bâtiment qui aujourd'hui crée
de l'emploi c'est sur la rénovation
l'efficacité énergétique
donc le fait de dire j'augmente cette
partie là et puis alors que le bâtiment
par ailleurs est dans une situation
extrêmement délicate nous semble être un
contre signal majeur voilà
j'ajoute que le ministre
de l'écologie a quand même dit qu sur au
moins le logement social il semblait que
le gouvernement soit susceptible de
bouger les lignes sur cette question là
nous on n'est pas fermé nous on a dit
que l'efficacité ça nous apparaît une
priorité essentielle
alors après les pouvoirs publics peuvent
tout à fait dire que dans l'efficacité
il ya des aspects vraiment qu'ils
méritent d'être mis 1,5 et d'autres qui
ne le méritent pas après c'est une
question de discussion ce que nous
disons c'est que ce n'est pas en
augmentant la tva qu'on va inciter les
agents à se mobiliser
là dessus et après on est dans une
situation de finances publiques nous on
n'est pas ne faisant pas la loi et c'est
pas nous a arbitrés pour savoir qu'est
ce qu'il faut équilibrer pour avoir le
budget d'état nous on dit simplement on
traite l'efficacité et si vous l'avez
traité correctement
ça fait deux fois de suite que la tva
augmente et plus personne n'y croit
voilà et donc c'est ce que nous disons
de la façon la plus claire alors sur le
compteur linky
effectivement il y avait il ya eu un
certain nombre de choses de financement
qui ont été prévus il se trouve qu'il ya
toujours des difficultés compliquée avec
la commission de régulation de l'énergie
sur la façon parce qu'en réalité la
question porte sur le fait de savoir si
on peut s'engager sur 20 ans avec des
tarifs d'utilisation qui sont fixés sur
quatre ans des tueurs fixé sur quatre
ans bon voilà est donc pour le moment on
est encore sur cette question là même si
des choses ont été faites
voilà voilà ce que je voulais dire je
passe la parole à anne sur quelques
points
innovation et complexité oui vous avez
raison
novation les complexités comme tout
changement il ya de la complexité
donc ce qui est intéressant c'est de se
dire qu'elle est l'accompagnement au
changement je pense que et or boucle sur
la formation 1re boucle sur un certain
nombre de choses
oui on peut pas nier une certaine
complexité mais à un moment la
complexité deviendra plus facilité donc
j'ai pas voyez ce gir cwy est à la fois
est-ce qu'il faut parce que y'a
complexité c'est dire qu'on ne va pas au
bout d'un certain nombre de choses donc
voilà c'est un peu précarité énergétique
vous en avez beaucoup reparlé et vous
avez raison
sur les ressources effectivement d'abord
pour dire pas eu le temps mais il ya des
programmes qui existent à habiter mieux
est un programme qui existent pour aider
au financement d'un certain nombre de
deux logements sur la précarité
énergétique il ya déjà des choses qui
existent
on a bien noté ceci dit dans notre
rapport dans notre avis un point
important c'est que il ya un certain
nombre de budget comme habiter mieux qui
sont aujourd'hui déjà fleischel qui sont
là mais il manque l'accompagnement il
manque les gens ils manquent on investit
sur le j'allais dire sur les frais de
rénovation mais on n'investit pas sur
l'humain qui accompagne et là je pense
que c'est un des vrais sujets c'est dans
les lignes budgétaires on ne doit pas
oublier surtout pour ça que ces
populations là qu'ils ne viennent pas au
guichet unique ce qu'on appelle temps
mais il ya eu chez unicredit mais qui
viennent pas forcément guichet unique
venir la chercher l'information
on a besoin d'avoir des gens qui
accompagnent et qui soit vraiment là
donc c'est important un point sur le lab
rica et énergétiques ce que je n'ai pas
dit mais c'est quand même très
significatif
un euro investi dans l'efficacité
énergétique ces 42 centimes d'économiser
en frais de santé
c'est une étude qui a été faite au plan
européen il n'y a pas d'études
françaises
un de nos nos recommandations sceptique
sur l'efficacité en ag énergétique en
france il n'y a jamais eu d'études
économiques macroéconomique réalisé sur
qu'est ce que ça veut dire d'investir
dans l'efficacité énergétique par
rapport aux autres sur un plan
macroéconomique je préfère le leur dire
aussi parce que ça n'existe pas on n'a
rien trouvé rien face existe peut-être
en tout cas on n'a pas trouvé en france
et puis vous parler du comportement oui
mais le comportement vous semblez dire
que quand on parle de comportement parle
de comportement que des citoyens pas que
on parle de tous les comportements
le premier comportement c'est le
gaspillage vous serez tout à fait
d'accord avec moi qu'il ya des gisements
économique et des gisements budgétaire
sur le gaspillage en france donc ça
c'est la première chose ça veut dire les
comportements donc de tous les acteurs
je donne juste un exemple sur
l'industrie parce que j'ai pas eu le
temps de le dire mais 70% de
l'électricité on estime que 70 %
d'électricité est utilisé en moteur en
là on l'a
n'allez est quasiment alors on n'a pas
trouvé de chiffres mais il nous a été
indiqué par plusieurs acteurs que
quasiment tous les moteurs sont
surdimensionnés partout on a toujours
des moteurs surdimensionné donc quand on
parle de comportement on parle aussi de
ça on parle du comportement des
collectivités on parle du comportement
de tout le monde face à une énergique et
aujourd'hui pas cher on a malgré elle et
malgré tout pas cher par rapport à ce
qu'elle sera très certainement et ce à
tous les acteurs en sont en sont
d'accord donc le comportement ça veut
dire quelles intentions mais d'abord sur
l'efficacité énergétique est pas on
n'est pas forcément dans un truc qui est
très restrictif c'est juste à un moment
ensemble
regardons ce qui est de façon très
pragmatique très pragmatique on parle
c'est une forme de sobriété
certes mais s'il parle de sobriété qui
est quand même à la mesure pour une
partie de beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'acteurs donc en tout cas il ya
vraiment des gisements là dessus qu'ils
sont qui sont importants et le
comportement du coup ça ça en fait
partie
merci donc vraiment je voudrais je pense
me faire l'interprète de tous mes
collègues pour vous remercier
les quatre rapporteurs endettés demande
un niveau que nous avons apprécié je
n'ai pas revenir sur les différents
intervenants mais je voudrais dire à
monsieur jacky chevrin que et aman aman
bettencourt que ce volet particulier du
bâtiment a fait l'objet d'un travail
important le président raul l'a rappelé
et que nous avons reçus dans l'autre
commission les responsables nationaux du
bâtiment du programme du bâtiment
durable et nous avons pointé
effectivement cette filière où il manque
qu'un certain nombre de maillots depuis
l'information jusqu'à la crédibilité de
sully qui fait le diagnostic celui qui
va accompagner humainement la décision
du futur commanditaire des travaux pour
effectivement je signale d'ailleurs que
les responsables nationaux du bâtiment
du plan bâtiment développement durable
sont à la disposition des élus pour se
rendre dans le département c'est ce que
je vais faire dans le mien pour essayer
de connecter l'information pour essayer
évident de motiver pour essayer de
parler d'un certain nombre de
dispositifs qui échappent parfois au fin
fond des provinces et je veux également
dire que évidemment suprême de la tva
est un problème sur lequel bon raul a
expliqué que nous étions en partie
d'accord pas tout à fait mais en partie
d'accord mais qu'il faudra certainement
faire un geste car nous avons aussi
entendu que il y à une menace de 40000
licenciements dans l'année 2013 et que
le premier trimestre 2014 à un carnet de
commandes relativement maigres dont on a
entendu tous ces messages et nous avons
tous la responsabilité des 6 des
répondants semblent avec ce volet voler
en quelque sorte de la prise de
conscience par les très très vite
consommateur qui doit évidemment faire
l'objet chacun à notre niveau d'une
forme de volontarisme politique donc il
faudra qu'on reparlera mais je crois
qu'on ne peut pas aller plus loin dans
la fin de cette audition sans donner la
parole anne marie ducroux qui a été je
trouve dans cette audition
un petit peu sacrifié donc si vous
voulez bien dire de mon ça me ferait
plus grand plaisir je pense que vous
avez vous en tant que responsable de la
section du cec
r pendant de pouvoir en quelque sorte à
mener une conclusion vu du côté donc du
csr
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
monsieur président je ne me risquerai
pas failli en conclusion une synthèse
vous imaginez bien je voulais d'abord
vous remercier d'abord de votre intérêt
pour nos travaux ça ça nous paraît très
essentiel parce que vous l'avez dit
monsieur raoult autant monsieur delevoye
que chacun des présidents de section et
jean louis schilansky qui n'est pas là
aujourd'hui pour la présidence de la
section des activités économiques est
attaché nous ayons vraiment des
relations entre assemblée qui soit
spontanée naturelle enrichissante
vous avez un rôle à jouer nous avons un
autre rôle nous essayons de réunir des
consensus et tout ce que nous produisons
et collectifs et dit quelque chose une
photographie d'un avis là un avis votez
et la photographie d'un équilibre auquel
nous sommes parvenus à un moment précis
sur un thème précis donc ça ça nous
paraît très important de gagner cette
coopération
je vois d'ailleurs que vous avez les
mêmes types de coopération que nous
parce que nous avons présentées de
manière conjointe deux avis issus de
deux sections différentes je vois que
vous faites des auditions communes nous
sommes très attachés à cette
transversalité à ce travail coopératif
donc je m'en réjouis j'espère qu'il y
aura d'autres occasions et tout
particulièrement je dois vous remercier
d'avoir donner aussi la parole la
section environnement parce que vous
l'avez bien en tête la section
environnement comme l'arrivée des
acteurs de l'environnement au ccs
précédents sont un des éléments de la
réforme du cso et cette section
environnement est nouvelle elle a un
mandat qui lui est dévolue par décret et
qui l'a mandat sur des questions très
vaste et j'espère que nous aurons sans
doute pas sûrs de nous revoir et nous
exprimer auprès de vous nous suivons les
questions de biodiversité de climat de
transition énergétique de risques
environnementaux au sens large de
protection de l'environnement au sens
large des questions de mers et océans
océans et qualité de l'habitat dont nous
avait parlé ce matin donc nous avons des
tas d'occasions nous saisir
nous sommes en train de produire un avis
sur la gestion durable et la gouvernance
des océans
vous savez que la france a une
responsabilité énorme une identité
maritime qu'il ignore trop souvent nous
avons vraiment la une un sujet à la
jonction des questions d'environnement
et d'économie et de société très
important donc j'espère ce sera
l'occasion de revenir vous vous en
parler nous préparons aussi un
it was in égalité sociale
environnementale sujet pas facile et
finalement vous l'avez évoqué à travers
les questions de transition énergétique
entre autres et nous aurons un excellent
ta vie je n'en doute pas sur
l'adaptation climatique avec quelqu'un
que vous connaissez qui sera co
rapportera nouveau jean jouzel avec une
académicienne membres de la section donc
j'espère ça nous aura d'autres occasions
de répondre à vos questions mais en tout
cas sachez qu'on est vraiment très
attaché à ce que vous jouiez votre rôle
que nous jouons notre rôle et qu'on
essaye d'enrichir nos réflexions
communes à chaque fois que possible
merci madame il aurait été dommage que
vous ne l'expliqué pas donc à moins que
daniel d'autres choses rajouter bien
coûter encore une fois merci
et puis nous avons pris un certain
nombre de rendez-vous à travers ces
échanges que nous essaierons de
respecter voilà merci à tous
voilà pour ces auditions consacrée à la
transition énergétique si vous souhaitez
les revoir elles sont disponibles sur
notre site internet publicsenat.fr bonne
journée à tous